aquí tenemos este ejercicio que nos pide
que construyamos un ángulo de 60 grados
y para eso nos dan un ángulo que podemos
ir moviendo podemos mover por ejemplo
este rayo que le pasó al rayo algo así y
el vértice y también podemos utilizar
este transportador y justo la idea es
utilizar el transportador para construir
este ángulo de acá para utilizar el
transportador lo que tenemos que hacer
es colocar el centro del transportador
en el vértice del ángulo
voy a pasar todo un poco más a la
izquierda algo más o menos por ahí el
transportador lo voy a poner justo en el
vértice y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
tomar uno de los rayos y hacer que
apunte hacia cero algo de este estilo
vale ahora para medir un ángulo de 60
tenemos que lograr que el segundo rayo
apunte hacia la medida de este centro
entonces voy a hacer justo eso voy a
hacer lo que apunte hacia acá y algo de
lo cual tenemos que tener cuidado es que
el ángulo esté midiendo pues justo la
medida que nos interesa aquí está
marcado en azul este cachito
hay que tener cuidado que no esté
marcado el otro cachito entonces ahí le
voy a poner comprobar respuesta correcto
y déjame ser un poco más específico con
la que me refiero en ocasiones si
tomamos este rayo y lo pasamos para allá
o para allá lo que empieza a medir es un
ángulo mucho más grandote que no es el
que nos interesa entonces aquí por
ejemplo parecería que estamos midiendo
un ángulo de 60 si éste va hacia 0 y
éste hacia acá pero en realidad estamos
midiendo otro verdad el que va de este
lado bueno vamos a hacer otro problema
vamos al siguiente construye un ángulo
de 155 grados muy bien este suena padre
porque es obtuso entonces misma idea
colocamos el transportador en el vértice
hacemos que un rayo apunte hacia cero
voy a moverlo tantito para que no quede
raro y hacemos que el otro apunte hacia
155 entonces es 40 50 60 70 80 90 aquí
llegamos a un ángulo recto 100 110 120
130 140 150
muy bien comprobar respuesta no es la
tuvimos mal porque porque aclaró porque
queremos 155 250 me muevo tantito más y
listo ahí está en 155 muy bien